i know that he's in a position now to be
able to invade
almost uh assuming that
the
ground is frozen above kiev
he has the capacity to do that what he's
going to do i don't know i don't know
that he's even made himself i don't know
that he knows what he's going to do
and i think he has to realize that it
would be a
gigantic mistake for him to move
on ukraine the impact on europe and the
rest of the world would be devastating
and he would pay a heavy price if uh if
russia invades uh that means tanks or
troops crossing the uh the border of
ukraine
again then uh there will be uh we there
will be no longer on our stream too we
we will bring an end to it
as i already said we are acting together
we are absolutely united and we will not
taking different steps we will do the
same steps and they will be very very
hard to russia and they should
understand
there is
no doubt in america's mind
that germany
is an incredibly reliable ally
and one of the leading physical powers
in
nato
number one
number two
the notion that north stream two would
go forward
with an invasion by the russians it's
just not going to happen
first of all we are looking at
opportunities to
make up for
lost
gas lng from
russia we're on their way of trying to
see what we can do to do that
dealing with our friends around the
world as well we think we could make up
a significant portion of it uh that
would be lost but you know what
everybody forgets here is russia
needs to be able to sell that gas and
sell that oil
russia relies a significant part of
russia's budget it's the only thing they
really have to export
and if in fact it's cut off then they're
going to be hurt very badly as well
and it's of consequence to them as well
this is not just a one-way street
and so
we are looking at what we could do to
help compensate for a loss of immediate
loss of gas
in europe if it occurs and
that's what we've been working on for
some time now